left-hander tyler gilbert the 27 year
old rookie gets the start tonight
just three career appearances all this
month all in relief his first major
league start is right now
and obviously you're hoping for a really
quick one two three first inning for
tyler gilbert let him get his feet
underneath him out there he's looked
very good in his three relief
appearances frazier one for four with a
single last night had an rb guy triple
thursday
slowly hit
and meet her ahmed and they roll it two
outs in the first machado steps in in
284 machado is down on strike swinging
so a nice inning for gilbert joe
musgrove on the mound for the friars
23rd start of the season second against
the diamondbacks this year
really good numbers consistent numbers
for joe musgroves approaching 130
innings and the opponent's batting every
jet sticks out
only 198 against joe musgrove
high drive out to deep right center
field back goes myers and it's off the
bottom of the wall
heading for second is van meter and
he'll get there standing with a double
that begins the bottom of the first
inning good start for the diamondbacks
van meter aboard in scoring position for
cattell martay here's the pitch and
that's line that's the base hitting the
left down the line van [ __ ] will come
around third score easily marty's into
second with an rbi double and back
back-to-back doubles to start the night
for the diamondbacks and it's a
one-nothing lead first and third nobody
out as drewble cabrera 3-1
third ball's in there that's in there
nodding is scott berry back there is
drooble's not happy you don't often see
him barking at umpires oh here's the 3-2
another curveball and as drooble has got
to be careful he's gone
you can see cabrera telling scott barry
that's your fault that's on you in the
meantime here's peralta who's
celebrating a birthday today he's 34.
peralta's got a base hit
haven hustling around second he's headed
for third martay is home and it's two
nothing diamondbacks
on two runs in and it's the rookie drew
ellis the start at third base tonight
ellis it's a fly ball to left
drew ellis that's gone his first career
home run
and make it five nothing diamondbacks
there you go
drew ellis in the books that's number
one
top of the third inning five nothing
diamondbacks will myers leading off
against the lefty tyler gilbert got him
went back to the cutter strikeout number
two for tyler gilbert in his first major
league start
two outs base is empty in the top of the
third inning five nothing diamondbacks
and joe musgrove at the plate here's a
2-2 and muscle strikes out swinging and
the side retired in order one two three
three strikeouts through knight batter's
face
nobody on david peralta left-handed
hitter
rbi single and a run scored in the five
run first inning bounced over the mound
can they get there cronenworth what a
play
he is a ball player and a half he's an
exceptional defensive player he
makes all the plays times the lead on
want to start things here in the fourth
for san diego now frazier who get into
that double play in the first take
another one of those
line to first and doubled off how about
that twice now frasier's into a double
play and that ball was just smoked and
uh sometimes you'll be a little lucky
guilford has yet to allow a hit two
quick outs here hosmer has rounded out
to second
fine right to tyler gilbert
five no hit innings for tyler gilbert
yeah dad he got it don't worry
and here is rojo for one earlhas had to
come in the ball game after as jubal
cabrera was ejected
rojas hammers one to center
and that's gonna get to the wall
haven smith on the move
he's coming home
it's an rbi triple for josh
and it's six-nothing d-backs and ross
continues his turret hitting against san
diego
27 year old rookie left-hander tyler
gilbert his first career major league
start he has yet to give up a base hit
well if he gets marishnik here
he'll be at the minimum face for six
innings 18 batters two times through the
order
fly ball out to left center peralta
has got it
tyler gilbert in his first major league
start a no-hitter through six josh van
meter what a day he's had in the
lead-off spot a double
a single in a walk he scored a run
and mater
that gets down in left center josh van
mader makes it seven nothing that's his
third hit tonight off watch to start the
seventh inning here comes frazier who
twice is it into a double play
line to third and ellis is there
drew ellis
oh there's your defensive play you need
one in every no no we're told and not an
easy play for drew ellis machado for two
haven smith has got it two outs in the
seven
bronenworth has twice flying out to
center
on the ground to second van meter
tyler gilbert
and his first career major league start
a no-hitter through seven gilbert no
hits through 70s at 88 pitches
fly ball to left off the bat of austin
nola
peralta's at the wall hey he's got it
well tyler's dad liked it in his d-backs
jersey the freight train
at the wall and left
cutter right on the inside corner you
can see tyler eyeball of that ball stay
in the park yes indeed
the gold glover david peralta up against
the wall
eric hosmer
ahmed is there
two outs in the eighth nice scoop by
payman smith there's tyler's dad he's
four outs away buyers over two
center field cattell marte
three outs on three pitches in the
eighth
he needs three more
this has been tyler gilbert's night just
three career major league appearances
all earlier this month all in relief
this is his first career major league
start
and he's three outs away trent grisham
the center fielder who has grounded out
twice will lead it off in the san diego
night one and two
carl strike three got him two outs to go
that's been a good pitch for him all
night long hassan kim will bet for the
pitcher two and two to kim
paul strike three ring him up he's one
out away and how about this
the last man standing for the padres
is the only guy that's been on base in a
san diego uniform tommy pham the leadoff
hitter has walked three times
center field martay it's a no winner
tyler gilbert
has thrown a no-hitter in his first
career major league start
the first diamondbacks picture
ever to throw a no-no in this ballpark
and just a third in their history